potin
has never lived a more loyal Squire
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video today I want to
continue doing my character breakdowns
for one of the lesser known characters
everyone has talked endlessly about John
Daenerys Cersei and all the other main
characters but I want to shed a little
light on someone that's usually off in
the background today I want to talk
about the lovable Podrick Payne now I
have to preface this by saying no one
really knows a whole lot about Podrick
so I really can't go too in depth with
him but I want to give my overall
predictions for how I see his own story
ending
Podrick is actually one of the very few
characters who doesn't really have any
dirt on his name but unfortunately for
Podrick his last name is Payne so he is
immediately associated with his cousin
Sir Ilyn Payne who was one of the most
despicable characters in my opinion sir
Ilyn Payne is best known for being the
executioner who beheaded Ned Stark but I
think Podrick has done a really good job
at separating himself from his family
some of you may not remember this but
Podrick did come very close to being
hanged before Podrick Metiria he was the
squire for Sir Lorimer and one night sir
Lorimer got very drunken he stole a ham
and he shared that ham with Podrick and
they were caught and sentenced to being
hanged but Podrick was spared because of
his last name it was because of this
that led Podrick to becoming Tyrion
squire as a form of punishment Tywin
sent Podrick to King's Landing to serve
his son Tyrion but I really wouldn't
consider that a punishment because I
think Podrick did enjoy his time with
Tyrion I also think it's safe to say
that Tyrion enjoyed his time with
Podrick as well all check
after a long consultation with my
colleague Brahm I finally found a
suitable reward for the services you've
provided over and above what might be
considered reasonable tell me Todd have
you ever been with a woman
thanks to Podrick Tyrion is actually
still alive
Podrick saved Tyrians life during the
Battle of Blackwater Bay
and I have a very good feeling Podrick
will save someone's life again one thing
I do know about Podrick is he is on his
way to becoming a formidable fighter
Podrick has been spending all of his
time would Bree in these last few years
in Brienne has been training him for
quite some time now we didn't see
Podrick that much in season 7 but when
we did see him he was getting knocked on
his ass but you have to admit Podrick is
training with one of the greatest
warriors of all time since the start of
this show I don't recall ever seeing
Bryan actually lose a fight so Podrick
can't ask for a better trainer right now
and I believe they keep showing us these
two sparring for a reason Podrick may
not be getting too many speaking scenes
but they keep reminding us that Podrick
is training were alight lessly and this
will have some sort of payoff in the
final season I know I said this in a
previous video but I believe we could
see Podrick kill a white Walker no one
would really expect Podrick to be able
to do this but I think he will surprised
everyone by how well he has adjusted to
his training almost everyone was
surprised when Podrick was the one who
saved Tyrion on the battlefield and I
just feel like he's gonna do that again
but this time it will be against the
dead he might even save Brienne and
that's how she will know that her
student has graduated it might not look
like Podrick is getting any better but
Bryan knows he is when songs are told
Brienne she was sending her to the
dragon pit for the parlay Brienne wanted
to leave Podrick behind to watch over
Sansa and that's because she was
confident in Podrick sibility let me at
least leave Podrick behind to watch over
you
he has become competent I do not need to
be watched over or minded or cared for
I'm not a child I am the lady of
Winterfell and I am home unfortunately
he does not have his own Valyrian steel
sword but John does have enough dragon
glass to arm just about everyone in
Winterfell so I think Podrick will have
some kind of dragonglass weapon during
the war against the army of the dead
there will be a lot of casualties during
this war but I don't think Podrick will
be one of them he won't defend himself
just fine and he will be one of the
characters who remain after all the
fighting is over I have always felt like
the survivors of this story would be
some of the characters who fall under
the cripples bastards and broken things
title those will be the characters who
survive at all
they were the underdogs of this story
who no one really gave a [ __ ] about nor
did anyone expect him to go far in this
world but the survival of the realm will
fall on their shoulders and they will do
whatever it is that needs to be done in
order for Westeros to see a brighter day
but with that being said I don't think
Podrick classifies as a crippled bastard
or broken thing but he is just like most
of them in a sense he doesn't come from
one of the major houses
he was never knighted nor did he become
a scholar but he will put his life on
the line to save those who can't defend
themselves they have kept this character
lingering around for a reason and I feel
like that's because they are going to
have him survive until the very end
there is really no reason to kill him
off now and since he has been training
day and night they must have plans for
him to step up in a time of need as of
right now he might be the last living
member of house Payne his cousin sir
Ellen pain is still alive but I don't
think we will ever see him again I think
he was completely written out of the
show so it will be on Podrick to carry
the torch for the future of his house
and you really can't ask for a better
man Podrick may not be as wise as
Saemaul Tarly or he might not have all
the glory on the battlefield like some
of the other characters but he does have
a good head on his shoulders
and he has been heavily influenced by
one of the most loyal characters in the
show and that will go a long way to how
Podrick approaches things in his own
life given what we know about him he
seems like a great character to help
make Westeros into a better place to
live than what it is car
now he's not an evil man and he's not
greedy or power-hungry either but I
don't want to sit here and try and get
too poetic with a character like Podrick
Payne because regardless of what I think
I still doubt they will dedicate too
much time on him he doesn't have much of
a speaking role as it is and there are
only a handful of episodes left but I
still wanted to give my thoughts on this
character he deserves to get his own
prediction video because I have high
hopes for this minor character I do hope
we get one more scene what Terri and
Paul jury can bran together again
what did you do to them lots of things
and they seem to like these things yes
of course they seemed to like it
they paid to seem to like it only they
weren't paid what you say these ladies
enjoyed him so much they gave him the
time for free is that what you're
telling us I already know Podrick and
Tyrion will be in Winterfell together as
they prepare for the war but I'm hoping
bran makes his way north also bran
really has no reason to stay in King's
Landing he can never fill many scenes
with Cersei because they have it set up
in their contracts to keep them away
from each other because of a real-life
bad breakup and now that Jamie is gone
he might as well head north too if he
ever wants to get his castle he's gonna
need to find Jamie or go get paid double
by Tyrion somehow someway I want one
last scene with these three together but
I don't want to get off-track ultimately
I think Podrick Payne will survive the
entire series when he proves himself on
the battlefield and all the wars are
over
Podrick will be relieved of his duties
as a squire that way he can live his own
life and do his own thing he might even
end up getting knighted but let me know
what you all think about this what do
you think Podrick will do next season
and do you think he will live put your
questions and comments down below let me
know which character you would like to
see me do next I want to thank everyone
for stopping by to watch the video I
really do appreciate that and I also
want to thank my supporters on patreon I
hope everyone has a great day I will see
you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]